when I wrote the script I don't I don't
think about casting just because it is
too specific to think about one actor
who you might or might not get so we
just try to write the characters as
clearly and as well as possible and not
not think about who would who would plan
and then as soon as it's done it's you
know you sitting with a producer and
what are we going to do who are we going
to go to and I to me Reggie was the lead
and I knew I had to cast Reggie first
and whether that actor became Ron as
well or didn't was was a different
matter or a different issue and not
knowing if the actor who would even want
to play both parts so you're opening the
idea of going one way the way either way
and knowing that oh one guy playing both
parts could be a gimmick that the film
doesn't survive but if you cast separate
guys and the second guy you cast is got
to look like the first guy so I mean
you're limited that way anyways I gave
it to Tom I didn't know him I really
liked him in the film warrior and
thought there was something Reggie Kray
like about about that performance and he
read it and we had dinner and all he
wanted to talk about was Ron all I would
apply Reggie he know he was too straight
for Tom it was too much of a leading man
for Tom and all I went on about was
Reggie and basically was kind of
standoff at dinner friendly standoff and
at the end of dinner he basically said
look I'll give you Reggie if you give me
Ron and I said oh that's a fair trade
okay and neither of us realized what a
dumb thing we had just or we neither
have to agree realize what we had just
agreed to i should say when you get that
idea there's obviously since the parent
trap the original Parent Trap film came
out there's been an evolution of
technology but I wonder at a certain
point you are using the same things that
the parent trap did in other words how
much does technology made your job
easier and how much is it still a pain
in the ass I know you
I don't think it's made it damaged
easier the parent trap is split screens
I think mostly and we mostly are split
screens because it's digital we have the
luxury of not having to have a vertical
line we're not to have one guy standing
in a doorway all the time so we can join
the two halves but it's the same idea
and then there's motion control if the
cameras moving but it was so the rigs
were so big and it took so long we
didn't we couldn't shoot too many of
them just because it took forever to get
a shot so how does Tom do the dialogue
is he listening to play back over
speaker does the IFB yeah weird were so
the tricks are the tricks I mean that
technology's you know you learn the
shots you can do when you do them in but
the bigger thing is the dynamic is
getting that dynamic between the two of
them and so he would come in in the
morning and we he'd always play Reggie
first and I'd read Ron and he'd read
Reggie and then he would flip and then
any kind of ad libs we had to work him
out then just sort of the two of us and
I always look to ad lib but but we
couldn't do it on set with another actor
so to speak with that energy between two
actors and the best way to describe it
is if you had made Butch Cassidy and the
Sundance Kid and and paul newman and
robert redford hated each other and
wouldn't be on set at the same time as
the other actor and that's basically
what he was up against so he he had to
even for example Ron is just stick he
likes a lot in waves cigars around and
things like that and on our overs we
shoot over on to Tom as Reggie and Tom
would have to think through what his
reactions were going to be teach him to
his body double and his body double
would do him first but Tom would would
work that out and we figure it all out
so that when Tom came in he could he
could slide into it otherwise the overs
wouldn't cut he when he was wrong he was
always in a really good mood
as an actor and always had his arm
around me and what are we doing and if I
said you know go over there and stand on
your head he'd say sure no questions or
anything like that and when he was
Reggie he was much more standoffish and
the crew loved Ron he was always like
hugging the crew and talking to them and
but when Reggie would show up he'd
always be on the edge of the set just
kind of observing everything and vaguely
suspicious of whatever you had to say to
him and I didn't tell him till the end
but it was you tell him what to they had
that there was a difference I don't
think he knew there was a difference but
uh it was much it wasn't easier direct
and Ron but it was more it was it was
just much friendlier and and Tom is
Reggie you had to make sure you had
answers to everything and and i think it
was how they were from what i've read it
was how they were in real life
especially when ron was in a good mood
if people have been to East London the
last couple of years they would know
that it's incredibly gentrified Google's
building an office there but what was it
like at that period and what did East
London represent to West London in terms
of the people who live there and what
they aspired to in West London well I
didn't you know they took it the worse
in the war as far as a bump being bombed
and it is you know there's the class
system in London that you know the if
you you're you're in the hole if you're
born in the east and the London and it's
a tough one to get out of but it was
very much you know like the East's of a
lot of cities you know the East End
Lower East Side in New York it's a place
that immigrants came through East LA and
so it's it's a from East Providence
which is similar the young but um it was
a place to land you know get started and
then move move out of and that's still
is that's still the case today was a
it's a very
I guess Pakistani neighborhood an Indian
neighborhood now and they were part of
that group and were you largely able to
film in East LA no no that neighborhood
is gone what you need where did you find
the neighborhoods you a little bit in
East London but all over the behind if
you know London behind Waterloo station
and in Greenwich and all over the city
and we just could find a couple of
little blocks here and there the my
location manager told me a very funny
story about a German director was there
and they were doing a Dickens novel I
forget which one and we'll just say it
was bleak house and he could never find
a reverse so they'd find a nice thing
here and then eat the reverse would be
some glass building and finally the guy
had a fit and said what is it with this
place you can't find a reverse anywhere
and the location manager said yeah
because because you guys blew all the
reverses up